that's what you get for calling me ugly
no not call you ugly I texted you saying
you're ugly hi my name is Sarah blank
I've known Mohammad for about six to
seven months now we dated for about
three months or so is short lived from
the beginning of the relationship he was
very consumed with work about a week or
two at the end of the relationship I was
leaving out of the country I was going
to Saudi Arabia for about ten days and
he made absolutely no time to see me and
that was my breaking point my name is
Mohammed Malik so Sarah and I were
together for two months it went pretty
well
it might in my opinion and went pretty
well for some people I'm Way too busy so
Sarah didn't like that I told her I
tried my best to to make the most time I
can for her but when I say like I don't
have time I mean it I don't have time
and that's how it ended over text I'd
like him in my life he inspires me I've
told him this over a text message but I
don't think I ever told him face to face
so that's going to be a little
interesting I think I'll be able to
describe him God and I think he'll be
able to describe me really well he's
very observant there's a few things I do
remember about Sarah but not everything
hi my name is Haven a cue from Los
Angeles California I'm an artist and
today I'm gonna be doing forensic style
drawings of couples based on their
descriptions and try to translate that
into an actual drawing when describing
their ex they can't have any emotion has
to be very clear you don't want to be
overly flattering just be
straightforward and just give it like it
is all right let's do this
basically would you say she has like a
thin face a round face a thin round does
that make sense because you have a big
head I think it's a medium-sized head
he's a little oval face how long does
her hair she wears a hijab so it's like
if someone was wearing a beanie but it's
not like all the way down to their
eyebrows yeah it's probably like to
their hairline her eyes are like almond
shaped but a little bit bigger big yeah
would you say she has a big lips no no
very has a very small upper lip he has a
beer you have a nice beer he has a um
small mustache with it you have a big
nose not big like vertically a little
bit big horizontally
he has a wide nose yeah and his bottom
lip is just a
midge bigger than his upper lip is he
sexy is her nose long or is it short or
I guess a pear-shaped what about our
eyebrows are they shaped them a bit Curt
they're not too six they're like
moderate sized anything else you could
think of that stands out with her spot a
man you guys ready to see the results
this is yours there's yours I look like
Drake with a beard this is great I can
get you too bad I looked I look like
Drake with a beard guys that's quite
accurate you got my nose and eyebrows
really like Donna No
after the break of it I tried to like
delete the image of him from my brain
not seeing each other after the breakup
and then seeing each other for the first
time was here it was a great way to
break the ice now it feels like
reconnected in the good way
[Music]
I'd like him in my life he inspires me
I've told him this over text message but
I don't think I ever told him face to
face I don't think I would pursue a
relationship with Sarah when we broke up
over text I I kind of thought it was
childish for me personally it's better
that we have a professional and like a
friendly relationship rather than having
a more intimate relationship I'm sorry
no don't apologize it's okay I'm sorry
too okay like well I was I was like like
I'm crazy
any like harder for you to say how you
felt cuz that's not that was not my
intention and when I did cut you off
it's because I need I needed to like
just recollect myself I was leaving the
Saudi idea I was like I'm sorry baby
come back for ten days you're gonna come
back I should have I should have totally
communicated didn't your fears -
absolutely you have a fire - so you
should have it's like I wanted something
wasn't asking for a lot that was just to
see you I wanted to see the guy liked at
that time I was just busy oh my god I'm
such a the excuses no such thing as
being too busy for someone it's a lot
that is no absolutely those were still
friends yeah don't do that I got
[Music]